المترجم: Alamir Mina
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
في منطقة اسمها تيزاي على الحدود السورية
تقع على الحدود بين سوريا وتركيا
كان يتواجد مجموعة من اللاجئين
وكنا متواجدين مع مجموعة من المتطوعين
لمدة أسبوع هناك
كان معنا طبيب مغربي اسمه أيمن بحبوح
عرض أن يقدم خدمات طبية داخل المنازل
لأي شخص لا يستطيع أن يغادر المنزل
وبالفعل احدى المتواجدات
طلبت من الطبيب أيمن
أن يأتي ليفحصها
كانت البنت مصابة إصابات بالغة
هي في العشرينات من عمرها، وليست طفلة
مصابة إصابة بالغة في منطقة الفخذ
مما جعلها عاجزة عن المشي
السبب -وهو شيء محزن- أنها لم تُعالج
بسبب عدم وجود كادر طبي نسائي
بمعنى، العادات والتقاليد
منعتها أن تُكمل حياتها بطريقة طبيعية
عندما أتى الطبيب ليوقع الكشف الطبي عليها
كانت تغطي الجرح، وتشعر بالخجل كثيراً منه
فكان الطبيب يحاول كشف الجرح،
وهي ما زالت خائفة
فذهبت إلى الطبيب لكي أساعده
لم أذهب معه كمصورة
برغم أنني ذاهبة هناك كمتطوعة -بشكل عام-
كصانعة أفلام
ولكنني ليست طبيبة معه، ولا مصورة
أنا فقط ذاهبة لكي أساعده
كنت أمسك الشاش بيدي اليمنى، والكاميرا
باليد اليسرى
وكنت أتمنى أن أوثق هذا المشهد
كيف خسرت البنت حياتها
بسبب العادات والتقاليد
وفي نفس الوقت اضطرت مجبرةً
أن ترى طبيب رجل
برغم أنها لا تشعر بالراحة، وخياراتها
المتاحة ضيقة جداً
حتى في موضوع العلاج، فلقد كان الخيار
إما أن أساعدها على أرض الواقع
بينما أمسك بالشاش بيدي اليمنى
أو أن أصورها وأنقل للعالم هذه الصورة
المأساوية الموجودة بتلك الغرفة
وهذا التحدي الذي يواجهه أي مصور
أو إعلامي أو صانع أفلام
ينتقل إلى منطقة يوجد بها مستضعفين
أو لاجئين
الإعلام، وأن يكونوا علي أرض الواقع
لتقديم الخدمة
ولكن هل كل مستضعف لاجىء؟
وهل كل مستضعف لا بد أن يكون مصاب
بحالة مرضية خطيرة ونقول عنه مستضعف؟
في الكثير من الفئات المجتمعية المجاورة لكم
يمكن أن تكون جارتكم، ويمكن أن تكون
جزء من عائلتكم
تعتبر أيضاً من الحالات الإنسانية المستضعفة
التي نحاول أن نسلط عليها الضوء في الإعلام
دعونا نشاهد هذا الفيديو الذي قمنا بإخراجه
منذ سنتين تقريباً
ووصل لعدد اثنين مليون ونصف المليون مشاهدة
وبعد أن سمعنا آراء الناس
اكتشفنا أنه يوجد أفكار
أثاروا انتباهنا إليها واستفدنا منها
هيا نرى العمل
(موسيقى)
منزلك جميل جداً، أتمنى أن تسعدي مع عريسك
أرجوك يا ابنتي، لا ترفعي صوتك على زوجك
يوجد شيء واحد آخر لا تفهميه
افعلي مثلي، أقرب طريق إلى قلب الرجل معدته
هل جننتي؟ ماذا تقولين يا ابنتي؟
هل تشتكين من زوجك وتسببين لنا فضيحة؟
هذا عيب، اسكتي لئلا يسمعنا والدك
يفعل معكِ هذه الأشياء ولا تزالين ساكتة؟
وماذا عن أولادِك؟
لا بد أن تخبري أحدا ما، لا بد أن تشتكيه
هذا نصيبك، أليس هذا أفضل من أن تصبحي عانس؟
(أصوات كثيرة متداخلة)
عندما يذهب إلى عمله، ارتدي له ملابس جميلة
وضعي العطر وتزيني
سيتوقف عن العصبية معكِ
يا حبيبتي، دللي زوجك يدللك
(تصفيق)
كان العمل لصالح موضوع،
وقبل أن ننتجه قمنا بعمل بحث عن الفئة
المعنفة من النساء
في منطقة الشرق الأوسط
في منطقة إفريقيا
واكتشفنا أن المنطقة الوحيدة في العالم
التي لا يوجد بها إحصائيات
عن النساء المعنفات، هي منطقة الشرق الأوسط
برغم أنها متقدمة تقنياً أكثر من بعض الدول
الآسيوية والإفريقية
ولكن السبب هو العادات والتقاليد
التي منعتها أن تتكلم
إذاً لنخرج من فكرة أن المستضعف
هو فقط اللاجىء
أو الفقير الذي نراه في الشارع
أحياناً اللاجىء هو، ليس أحياناً بل دائماً
اللاجىء هو شخص فقد حقوقه
أو تعرض لظلم في مرحلة من مراحل حياته
ويعاني من نقص أساسي من أساسيات الحياة
من ماء شرب أو تعليم
نحن من يقرر الكادر الذي نضع فيه صورنا
كصناع أفلام أو مصورين
والكثير من الصور تروها، وأحياناً تعترضوا
أن تلك الصورة مذلة أو مهينة لهذا الطفل
والبعض منها قد يصل إلى عشرة آلاف مشاركة
إن القرار-أولاً وأخيراً- يقع بين يدي
من يقف خلف الكاميرا
أو خلف القلم
لقد اخترت أن أضع المرأة التي رأيتموها
في سياق المرأة العاملة في المنزل
والتي تقوم بتربية أطفالها
وواضح أنها لا تخرج للعمل، أليس كذلك؟
ولكن هل هي الوحيدة المعنفة؟
يمكن أن تكون المرأة التي تعمل وزيرة
أو بمنصب نائب معنفة.
ولكنها لا تخبر الناس بسبب مكانتها المرموقة
في المجتمع.
لذا قمت -كصانعة أفلام- باختيار
أي سياق أضع به المرأة
مما سيؤثر على الصورة النمطية
التي اعتدتوا أن تروا بها المعنفات
أنهن من يقمن بتربية أطفالهن
أو المقيمات في منازلهن.
برغم أن تلك الصورة صحيحة، ولكن ليست
هذه هي الصورة الوحيدة الصحيحة.
محمد وعبد الكريم صبيان من النيجر
تعرفت عليهما خلال رحلة تطوعية إلى هناك.
يحبان مدرستهما كثيراً
فيذهبا إلى المدرسة مشياً لمدة ساعة
ذهاباً وإياباً.
وبعد المدرسة يرجعا إلى مستشفى
لمراقبة الطبيب لتجهيز العمليات الجراحية
أو القيام بالتمريض.
وذلك أملاً منهما
أن يصبحا طبيبين في المستقبل.
مدرستهما ضعيفة التجهيز بشكل كبير
وليس من السهل أن يصبحا طبيبين في مجتمع
ذو موارد محدودة جداً.
هذا جزء من القصة.
محمد وعبد الكريم كلاهما متفوق في المدرسة.
ولم يتصورا معي لأنني المتطوعة
ولكن لكي يخبروني بأن المرة القادمة
التي سيأخذون فيها صور معنا
سنكونا مرتديان رداء طبيب.
كلتا القصتان صحيحتان
ولكن في أحدهما أحسستم
كيف يمكن أن يساعدوا أنفسهم،
والقصة الأخري أشعرتكم بمدى تفوق هذين
الشابين في المدرسة
وأنهما يتحدان مجتمعهما ذو الموارد المحدودة
حتي يتخرجا بعلم، وبشهادة الطب.
في نفس الرحلة إلى النيجر ذهبنا لعلاج مجموعة
أشخاص مصابين بداء المياه الزرقاء
مما يسبب العمى الجزئي، ولكن بعد فترة طويلة
أعني هناك أشخاص ظلوا عميان لمدةعشر سنوات
بسبب عدم توفر مائة دولار
فكان مطلوباً
-برغم أنني لست طبيبة- التوثيق.
أي إما أقوم بتصويرهم
قبل أو بعد إجراء العمليات
لكي أرى الحالة التي مر بها المريض
قمت بأخذ جولة حول المستشفى
حتى أرى الوضع قبل العمليات.
كانوا جميعاً خائفين، يضعون ضمادات،
ولا يمكنهم المشي.
ولذا كانوا يبتعدون عن الكاميرا
لذا فقررت أن أقوم بتأجيل التصوير
حتى بعد العمليات.
وأخبر المتبرع بأن تبرعاته جعلت الناس
بهذه الطريقة التي ستروها
أناس ذوي وجوه مبتسمة
كل هذه الوجوه كانت تشعر بالخجل والإرتباك
ولا تود الظهور بالإعلام.
فقمت بإعطاهم الخيار هل تودون الظهور
مبتسمين أم حزينين
وعملي كصانعة أفلام أن أحكي القصة
وراء كل صورة.
من جديد، الصورة التي ترسموها،
السياق السلبي أو الإيجابي،
المرأة الحزينة العاملة في المنزل،
أو المرأة التى تعمل كوزيرة
أنتم من يقرر اختيار السلبي أو الإيجابي
كلاهما صحيح
ولكن ترسموا صورة نمطية
للشخص الموجود داخل الإطار.
عمل آخر قمنا بإخراجه
سأخبركم بملاحظة غيرت كثيراً في طريقي
المهني، وطريقة نظرتي للأمور.
هيا نشاهد الفيديو التالي والذي حقق مليون
مشاهدة، وقرأنا كل التعليقات بشأنه
وذلك بهدف تطوير العمل
اسمي سامي، وأنا أحب أهلي كثيراً
أكثر وقت أحبه عندما أشاهد المباراة مع أبي
وأيضاً أحب أن أعلم أختي سارة الرسم
لأنني فنان أكثر منها.
أحيانا -في الليل- أحب أن ألعب بمفردي
لا يغضب مني أحد حتى لو كانوا نائمين
عندما أرى أمي مشغولة كثيراً أذهب لمساعدتها
لكي لا تتعب
أزرع معها الورد، وأرويه حتى ينمو سريعاً
أنا شجاع، لا أخاف
أنا لا أخاف في المنزل
ولكنني أخاف عند الخروج منه
لماذا ينظر الجميع إلي هكذا؟
ولكن لا أحد ينظر إلى سارة
وحتى عندما أريد أن ألعب الكرة مع أصدقائي
لا يسمحوا لي بمشاركتهم
لماذا يبتعدون عني؟
ماذا فعلت لهم؟
(تصفيق)
فئة أخرى مستضعفة، ومظلومة في المجتمع
ولكننا لا نذكرها بكثرة
لأننا -تلقائياً- نعتبره شخص غريب، وبالتالي
ينظر له المجتمع نظره غريبة
ننسى أنه هو أيضاً من الجهات المستضعفة
التى تحتاج إلى حماية
وتحتاج إلى تسليط إعلامي
عدد أعمال الفيديو التي تتحدث عن الطفل
المصاب بمتلازمة الداون ضعيف جداً
يمكنكم -عند العودة إلى منازلكم- البحث
على موقع يوتيوب
صراحةً العدد ليس فقط ضعيف، ولكنه محزن
وكأن هذا الطفل يولد في أمريكا ولا يولد
في دول عربية.
أنتم من يختار السياق، وترسموا صورة نمطية
للشخص الذي تريدون تصويره.
عندما قمت باختيار الطفل سامي ليلعب دور
الطفل، هو أساساً مصاب بمتلازمة داون.
استقبلت تعليقات فتحت عيوني لأشياء
لم أكن منتبهة لها.
أخبروني بأنه يوجد لديهم أمثال هؤلاء، ولكن
يوجد البعض منهم يتزوج
يوجد منهم من يتزوج، ومنهم من يصبح موظف
صحيح أنهم يواجهون التحديات
ولكننا جميعاً نواجه تحديات
ولكنهم يواجهون تحديات
أكبر من غيرهم
أنتي أظهرتيه بأنه مُحزن كثيراً
وهذا صحيح، أنه محزن كثيراً، وأنه يعاني
كثيراً من هذه المشكلة
هذا ليس فقط محزن، ولكن بإمكانه أن يستمر
في حياته
الخلل ينبع منّا نحن وليس منه هو
أنا لم أظهر أي صورة إيجابية في حياته
لقد فتح ذلك عيوني بأنني عندما أنقل صورة
لشخص، يجب أن أدرس الجانبين
وأحدد أيهما يمكنني أن أستغله بشكل أفضل
بالنسبة لي وبالنسبة له.
وهذا هو الأهم.
لقد أثرت الصورة النمطية على أرض الواقع،
وليس فقط على الصورة الذهنية لديكم.
عندما خرج اللاجىء السوري من سوريا،
وصار الجميع يتحدث عن أنه جائع وعطشان
ولا يجد الكساء.
ويبحث لعائلته عن مأوى...ألخ
أدى هذا إلى تطبيق واقعي
على أرض الواقع في أوروبا
أنه ممنوع من دخول العديد من الدول الأوربية
عندما أُجريت الدراسات، وسُئل الأوربيين
"لماذا لا تريدون دخول اللاجىء السوري؟"
البعض أجابوا أنهم يخافون من الاغتصاب،
ومنهم من يخاف القتل، ومنهم من يخاف السرقة
وبالتالي فالصورة النمطية لديهم أن اللاجىء
مستعد أن يفعل أي شيء في سبيل لقمة العيش
مما أدى إلى خوف الناس من هذا اللاجىء.
هذا ما توضحه الإحصائيات
وليس مجرد كلامي.
لقد نسينا عندما كنا نتحدث عن السوريين
أن نذكر أحلامهم
لقد كانوا في سوريا أطباء، ومهندسين
لقد امتلكوا بيوت وفيلات وسيارات
ليس جميعهم، البعض منهم كانوا مزارعين
وكانوا يتملكون أراضي زراعية، ومواشي.
لقد كانوا يعيشون من عرق جبينهم
لقد خاف الناس منهم بسبب الصورة
التي صورناهم بها في الإعلام.
وأدى إلى أن معظم الرافضين، وهم 73 بالمائة.
يوجد دولة بها نسبة 73 بالمائة يرفضون دخول
اللاجىء السوري لبلادهم.
في دراسة أجرتها منظمة ادويكس
سُئِلت عن أكثر المقالات عدداً
من حيث القراءة على موقعها
وقالت أن نسبة 60 بالمائة من المقالات
الأكثر قراءةً هي المقالات السلبية
والتى تحتوي على كلمة قتل،
تهديد، تجويع، قتلى، وفاة
وبالتالي تعمل هذه الكلمات
كمنبهات عند الإنسان
الإنسان بطبيعته كائن دفاعي
على سبيل المثال عندما يضع الطفل الصغير يده
على الماء الساخن، ماذا يفعل؟
يدافع عن نفسه.
عندما يسمع صوت مخيف، ينكمش على نفسه.
حتى أنتم، لو سمعتم الآن صوتاً بالخارج،
ستشعرون سريعاً بالخوف.
الإنسان بطبيعته دفاعي
عندما تسمعون بعض الكلمات، تنتبهون
تلقائياً بأنني يجب أن أدافع عن نفسي
وهذا ما تفعله العناوين
التي تحتوي على كلمات مثيرة
ستشاهدون من الآن فصاعداً على إعلانات
وستكتشفون مدى صدق هذه الكلمة
وهناك قول مأثور في اللغة الإنجليزي يقول
"If it bleeds, it leads"
بمعنى أنه إذا كان العنوان دموي،
وليس بالضرورة نفس كلمة دموي
بقدر ما هو مؤلم
فهذا يعني أنه سيحضر الكثير من الجمهور،
والشهرة
وبالتالي سيجني المصور مزيداً من الأموال
بين هذه الحلقة الثلاثية، يكون الضحية هو
الشخص المستضعف
والذي على أكتافه يمكن أن يتم إحضار دعم
ولكن يتم استغلاله.
عندما يتناول أحدكم قرص بانادول، يكون لها
مفعول ممتاز في أول مرة
وأيضاً مفعولها ممتاز في ثاني مرة.
ولكن بعد عامين، تصبحون في حاجة إلى قرصين
وبعد ثلاثة أعوام تحتاجون ثلاثة أقراص.
ومع كثرة استخدام الأدوية، يصبح جسدكم مخدر.
وهو ما يسمى في الطب Tolerance
ويعني ذلك توقف جسمك عن الإستجابة
للمنبهات التي تتناولوها
لأنكم تتناولوها كثيراً
وهو نفس الشيء الذي يحدث لديكم عندما
تقرأون الكلمات السيئة باستمرار.
لقد عملت على كتاب يسمى "مسلمي العالم"
ويعتبر بالنسبة لي من أهم المشاريع
التي عملت عليها
إذ أنني سافرت إلى سبع دول حول العالم
أجمع فيها قصص ملهمة لمسلمين حول العالم
لقد كانت قصص مؤلمة جداً، ومع ذلك فكان
عملي أن أستخرج منها قصص ملهمة
وما أثبت لي أن القصص الملهمة يمكن أن تنجح مثل
القصص السلبية التي تصل لعدد كبير من الناس
ويقوموا بعمل مشاركة لها، ويحزن عليها الناس
ولكنهم لا يتفاعلون
دعوني أعرض لكم قصة سارة
سارة إنسانة لا تبصر، ولكنها
لم تخبر الناس بذلك
ولكنها أخبرت الناس عن التطبيق الذي تعمل عليه
لكي تساعد الأشخاص غير المبصرين.
عندما تحدثت في قديماً عن سارة
بأنها لا تبصر
تجاوب الجميع قائلين
"أعانها الله".
ولكن عندما تحدثت عن التطبيق الخاص بها
هل تعرفون بماذا أجاب الجميع؟
"كيف يمكننا أن ندعم التطبيق؟"
وبالتالي تحدثنا عن جانب إيجابي
في حياة سارة.
رانيا الخطيب التي تعرضت للتحرش بسبب
حجابها والإسلاموفوبيا "الخوف من الإسلام"
كان من الممكن أن أظهرها كمستضعفة.
ولكن على الجانب الآخر أظهرتها كطبيبة حاصلة
على درجة الدكتوراة PhD من أمريكا
فأنت من تختار السياق الذي تضع فيه الشخص.
كتاب "مسلمين حول العالم" الذي جمعت فيه
قصص ملهمة حول العالم
الآن -بفضل الله- ينافس على أفضل رف
في نيويورك "New York Best Seller"
أي الأكثر مبيعا في نيويورك.
والذي يحمل قصص مؤلمة جداً ستجلعكم جميعاً
تبكون كما بكيت عندما سمعت هذه القصص.
كل قصة كانت تستغرق أربع أو خمس ساعات
لكي أكتبها.
ولكن في النهاية يوجد بها خيط مشترك
بينك وبينها،
وهو ما يدفعك للرغبة في مساعدتها
وتقدم لها العون
ولا تتحدث عنها بأنها حالة ميؤوس منها
وأنك لا تستطيع مساعدتها.
قد أخطيء غداً وأقوم بتصوير صورة ما
ثم أندم علها، وهكذا وأظل أتعلم
ولكنني موجودة معكم اليوم
لنتذكر معاً شيء واحد
وراء كل مشهد، ووراء كل صورة لمستضعف
توجد هناك قصة إنســـان
شكراً
(تصفيق)